WT Stead, the Father of Investigative Journalism
Victorian era Britain was a time of massive
change.
From sweeping imperialist expansion abroad
to political and social reform at home, to
the rise of mysticism, spiritualism, and romanticism,
the nation was growing and, in many ways,
thriving.
For some, cities were becoming bustling, prosperous
hubs of industry, but for the less fortunate,
they also became cesspools of disease, darkness,
and misery.
It was an era of invention and advancement,
and Britain's citizens learned about it through
the newspaper.
Before the modern era of journalism, there
was once a time when the newspaper was simply
for reporting the news.
However, a young editor named WT Stead saw
the potential for it to be something more
-- at one point, he described his vision to
a friend as "a glorious opportunity of attacking
the devil."
And he did.
There were plenty of devils out there, rearing
their ugly heads during this time of all-encompassing
change.
Not only did he attack them, but people listened,
and he proved that one person really can be
the voice that changes history.
This is Stead’s story.
TITLE: A world shaped by the newspaper
Today's world is connected in ways the average
Victorian-era citizen could never have believed.
News travels fast, they say, and today, that's
certainly true.
It was quite a bit less true in the 19th century,
so when newspapers became widely accessible
in the mid-1800s, it quickly shaped the daily
operation of entire cities.
Typically, newspapers were the only way people
would hear about wars in far-away lands or
the goings-on of their own governments.
That made them powerful, and many built massive
and ornate buildings that towered over the
worlds they reported on.
Since not everyone could afford to buy their
own paper, public social clubs were formed
and reading rooms were built, where hundreds
of members could get together to share papers,
read the news, and discuss.
Others headed to the pubs, where landlords
kept papers on hand and sometimes paid speakers
to perform the news to raucous applause.
There were more newspapers in public libraries
than there were books, newsagents popped up
everywhere, and newsboys hawked the latest
edition with the help of signs proclaiming
the day's headlines.
Suddenly, everyone was learning about the
world, and they only wanted more.
William Thomas Stead was brought into that
rapidly changing world on July 5, 1849.
Born a minister's son, he could read both
Latin and English by the time he was five
years old, and it would be his words that
would not only shape his own life, but go
on to change the world he lived in.
Even though it had originally been assumed
that he would follow in his father's footsteps
and become a minister, that's not what happened
at all.
After finishing his schooling, he ended up
working as a clerk in a merchant's office
in Newcastle.
While he was there, he was a regular contributor
to a newspaper called the Northern Echo.
The editor, John Copleston, saw something
valuable in him and mentored him for a surprisingly
short time.
The paper opened in 1870, Stead got his foot
in the door, and in 1871, the owner of the
paper offered him his mentor's job.
At the time, Stead had never even stepped
into the paper's offices.
Stead hesitated, as he was loathe to take
the job of a man who had been such an inspirational
teacher and mentor to him.
But when Copleston left voluntarily, he rose
to the challenge, becoming the country's youngest
newspaper editor.
It was a huge task, and to Stead, it was a
chance to make a monumental contribution to
society.
He wrote, "I felt the sacredness of the power
placed in my hands, to be used on behalf of
the poor, the outcast, and the oppressed."
And that's exactly what he did.
His goal was to create a newspaper that was
just as entertaining as it was informative,
one that would reach the masses and spur them
to action.
He started out in the most shocking way possible,
with a topic he'd revisit later: prostitution.
He called it "the ghastliest curse which haunts
civilised society," and at the time he was
splashing it across the front page, it was
such a taboo subject that talking about it
was just as illicit as partaking in it.
Stead's condemnation of prostitution wasn't
quite universal, though -- at the same time
he condemned the wealthy echelons of society
for funding brothels, he acknowledged that,
for many, it was the only way they could put
food on the table.
Stead's preaching from the pulpit and his
almost sermon-like articles set the tone for
the Northern Echo and for the rest of his
career.
He condemned entire nations for their politics
and their human rights abuses, and he waxed
philosophical on why the death penalty was
a necessary evil.
That was a viewpoint that was a bit problematic,
considering the paper was funded by Quakers,
a religious group who believed there is a
bit of God in everyone, and that all life
is valuable.
It wasn't long before Stead grew too big for
the Northern Echo, and headed to London to
take up with The Pall Mall Gazette.
TITLE: New Journalism
Stead continued his fire-and-brimstone flavor
of journalism when he got to London, but it
wasn't particularly popular.
Some of his contemporaries hated him as much
as he hated London, and no one made a secret
of it.
At the same time Stead called the bustling
metropolis "the grave of all earnestness",
his paper was nicknamed the "Dunghill Gazette"
by poet Algernon Swinburne.
Novelist Mathew Arnold was more direct, calling
Stead's sensationalist style "feather-brained".
But as much hate as he got, he also got results.
In 1883, the clergyman Andrew Mearns wrote
a pamphlet called "The Bitter Cry of Outcast
London".
It detailed the plight of the countless souls
living in the slums of the city, and it was
dire stuff.
He wrote:
"Few who will read these pages will have any
conception of what these pestilential human
rookeries are, where tens of thousands are
crowded together amidst horrors which call
to mind what we have heard of the middle passage
of the slave ship.
To get to them you have to penetrate courts
reeking with poisonous and malodorous gases
arising from accumulations of sewage and refuse
scattered in all directions and often flowing
beneath your feet; courts, many of them which
the sun never penetrates, which are never
visited by a breath of fresh air, and which
rarely know the virtues of a drop of cleansing
water."
If it wasn't for Stead, the pamphlet might
have gone unnoticed.
But the journalist picked it up and ran with
it, using The Pall Mall Gazette as a megaphone
for Mearns’ monologue.
Consequently, the paper increased its reputation
for sensationalism and scandalous stories,
as its readers were outraged at the lurid
tales about what missionaries would find in
the slums of London.
The paper spoke of dozens of people, huddled
together in the dirt and squalor, of children
poisoned by the foul stench, of child corpses
and vermin abandoned to rot the darkness.
The outrage of these freshsly realized details
didn't just disappear.
Mearns' words and Stead's relentless promotion
of the pamphlet resulted in new housing legislation
and the organization of missions throughout
London, whose only goal was to alleviate some
of the suffering and misery described in the
macabre tales.
The next year, Stead picked up another cause:
the Navy.
Calling for an end to party squabbles in the
interest of national security, he appealed
to the government to make sure its fighting
fleet was, indeed, capable of fighting.
The result was the government making a £3.5
million investment into upgrading its fleet,
a staggering amount for the time.
Clearly, readers were listening.
TITLE: The Maiden Tribute of Modern Babylon
Stead's tour de force came in 1885, published
under the sensationalized headline "The Maiden
Tribute of Babylon."
This is when he returned to a subject that
he had condemned earlier — prostitution.
This time, he was kicking the door wide open
on one of the darkest areas of London's seedy
underbelly, and that was the selling of virgin
children to men who were wealthy & debased
enough that they found no greater pleasure
in life than [quote] "the exclusive luxury
of revelling in the cries of an immature child."
Stead didn't just write about it second-hand
-- he spent four weeks in the streets, brothels,
and hospitals of London, meeting with everyone
from doctors and bishops to those deemed "procuresses."
These were people willing to find and broker
deals for human flesh and services.
He thoroughly documented all that he found,
describing the London underworld as a place
"with all the vices of Gomorrah, daring the
vengeance of long-suffering Heaven."
The story that unfolded on the pages of The
Pall Mall Gazette was horrifying.
Stead secured a meeting with a contact who
was connected to all sorts of crime in the
city's underbelly.
When he inquired about purchasing a virgin
girl for his pleasure, he was told that wouldn't
be a problem.
When Stead began to ask more questions about
any potential consequences attached to his
actions, he was further assured that screams
would not be investigated and legal action
would not be pursued.
He quoted his source as saying, "Whom is she
to prosecute? … who would believe her?"
Stead, incredulous, asked for confirmation
that these unspeakable procurements were common,
and was not only assured that they were, but
was told, "And you cannot help it, as long
as men have money, procuresses are skillful,
and women are weak and inexperienced."
It was something the stalwart journalist could
not walk away from, and could not let continue
to happen while he stood idly by.
But just the word of a seedy soul prowling
the shadows of London wasn't going to be enough
to instigate the change Stead wanted to see.
He knew he needed proof, and started by finding
and interviewing former brothel owners and
those whose innocence had been sold.
It wasn't long before he met a working brothel-keeper
who promised it would only take him only a
few days to find several virgin girls — whose
untouched condition was verified by a doctor.
Stead backed away from communication with
this man, but it wasn't long before he found
one of these virgin girls, grown and turned
procuress, who was willing to reach out to
old contacts and find him the sort of girl
he was asking for.
The price?
£3 to £5.
As Stead waded deeper, he found that crude
medical procedures and violent assaults didn't
bring an end to the nightmare the children
were sold into.
Many children, most of whom were orphans or
had no family to speak of, were generally
passed along to brothel-owners to fill their
ranks, or ended up on the streets making a
living any way they could.
And there were plenty of options, as Stead
would write: "Anything can be done for money,
if you only know where to take it."
Stead was careful to say that he knew everything
he said was true, that it wasn't just sensationalist
nonsense… because he oversaw the negotiation
and purchase of a 13-year-old girl.
Her name was Lily, and she had a family who
agreed to sell her as a household servant.
A procuress paid her parents £5, and she
bid them goodbye.
She was washed and dressed, and Stead's description
of her makes it somehow even more heartbreaking.
She could read and write, he wrote of her
as "a loving, affectionate child, whose kindly
feeling for the drunken mother who had sold
her into nameless infamy was very touching
to behold."
She was "full of delight at going to her new
situation," he wrote, stressing that even
though her parents knew what was going to
happen to her, she hadn't a clue.
Her status as a virgin was verified by a midwife,
the purchaser was supplied with some chloroform,
and Stead recorded everything — including
the names of the people involved.
He immediately published the story.
That public was outraged, and Stead got all
the reaction he could have hoped for… and
then, a little bit more.
On a national level, the expose sparked the
passing of the Criminal Law Amendment Act
of 1885, which laid the groundwork for other
legislature designed to protect women and
girls who were forced into prostitution, and
it also raised the age of sexual consent from
13 to 16 years old.
For the part he played, Stead found himself
in front of a judge, brought up on charges
of abduction and indecent assault.
When Justice Henry Charles Lopes handed out
the sentence, he explained that Stead's experiment
had failed, because he hadn't bought a child
for exploitation at all… he had rescued
her before anything bad had actually happened
to her.
And that meant he had published what the judge
ruled "a distorted account of the case", and
called it "a disgrace to journalism."
Stead was sentenced to six months' jail and
hard labor, a sentence backed up by the fact
he had technically broken the law by getting
only her mother's permission to buy her, not
her father's as well.
The sentence was considered less about the
law and more about what Stead had done.
Mostly, his jailtime was thanks to the people
who truly hated him — the wealthy men in
power, the ones whose actions he had a tendency
to condemn in a humiliatingly public way.
TITLE: The eccentric nature of brilliance
After Stead's stint in jail, he was never
quite the powerhouse of journalism he had
been.
That’s not entirely because of how his expose
on child prostitution ended, though; in the
grand scheme of things, it was a huge success.
But for years, he had preached some unpopular
opinions, including advocating for Ireland’s
self-governance, as well as forming closer
ties with both the U.S. and Tsarist Russia.
When he took over at The Pall Mall Gazette,
he had decreased his popularity by doing something
revolutionary: introducing decidedly American
features into British papers, like large-print
headlines, bylines for his reporters, and
celebrity interviews.
There were a few other things Stead did that
raised some eyebrows, including offering his
unwavering support to the establishment of
Esperanto as a global language, vocalizing
his opposition to British military endeavors
like the Second Boer War, and suggesting that
the nations of the world needed to form something
he dubbed Union International, which would
have been a version of the United Nations
dedicated strictly to global peacekeeping
and anti-militarism.
But it was actually an element of his personal
life that eventually gave 19th century Britian
its biggest pause, as Stead was also a devoted
spiritualist who may have been a little too
radical, even for Victorian Britain.
And that's saying something -- the spiritualism
movement had been wildly popular since the
Fox sisters claimed to have channeled the
spirit of a murdered man in 1848 and established
contact with the other side.
The idea that it was possible to contact loved
ones who had passed on was obviously enticing,
and it gained some serious traction within
a select sliver of the population, including
Stead.
Stead left The Pall Mall Gazette in 1890,
and founded not only The Review of Reviews,
but a spiritualist quarterly called Borderland.
The publication was a sort of news outlet
for the supernatural, and included everything
from astrological predictions and news stories
about ghosts and seances to reports on research
conducted on the occult.
For Stead, this wasn't a new fascination,
either, as he reportedly experienced some
otherworldly phenomenon as a young man visiting
Hermitage Castle in Scotland.
It wasn't until 1892 that he saw someone practicing
automatic writing -- the idea that some men
and women could channel spirits to write through
them.
At first, he didn't subscribe to the idea,
but after giving it a try, he claimed to have
made contact with an American journalist named
Julia Ames.
Ames had died in 1891, not long after she
interviewed Stead.
It didn't end with just making contact.
Stead went on to write an entire book called
Letters From Julia, where he both received
messages for a friend of the late journalist
and talked to her himself.
They talked about grief, about the discovery
of the afterlife, of spiritual growth, of
loss and of hope.
Regardless of how inspirational the letters
were, Stead's obsession with spiritualism
serious eroded his credibility in the journalistic
world.
But if there's anything we know about Stead,
it's that he wasn't easily swayed by an unfavorable
public opinion.
He went on to found an organization called
Julia's Bureau, which was a group founded
with the goal of, according to him, "attempting
to bridge the abyss between the Two Worlds."
The idea, he said, was that when loved ones
passed on, they weren't just floating aimlessly
or off to sit on some clouds and play some
harps.
They were more alive than they had ever been
before, and in desperate need of comforting
the grieving souls who had been left behind.
He appointed what he called "competent sensitives"
to the bureau, and their goal was a specific
one.
They were only to be used by living applicants
who were looking to reach out to those they
had loved and lost.
Stead likened the bureau mediums to policemen
who reunited lost and frightened children
with their frantically searching mothers.
And he wasn't doing it alone — Julia was
on the other side, he said, guiding his efforts.
Julia's Bureau was only active for around
three years, and in that time, they worked
with hundreds of grieving people and passed
on countless messages.
It cost Stead around £1,500 pounds a year
to run, and it ended with his death.
But that's not the end of his story.
TITLE: Eerie prophecies and a sinking ship
Toward the end of his life, Stead was derided
and ridiculed for his unwavering belief in
spiritualism.
And in all fairness, he certainly wasn't the
only believer — Sir Arthur Conan Doyle famously
became a spiritualist, his beliefs cemented
in the face of the senseless loss of life
that happened during the First World War.
But sometimes it's only in hindsight that
certain things become clear, and in Stead's
case, he penned some eerie tales that will
make even the staunchest skeptic think twice.
In 1886, Stead published a bit of cautionary
fiction in The Pall Mall Gazette.
It was called "How the Mail Steamer went down
in Mid Atlantic, by a Survivor," and it was
the story of a steamer ship carrying 916 passengers
when it collided with another vessel and sank.
The story was in response to legislation that
dictated that the number of lifeboats a ship
needed to carry was based on the size of the
vessel, not on the number of passengers.
Stead described the sinking of the ship in
agonizing detail, narrating the hundreds of
people who had been dumped into the water,
the narrator finding himself "amid a blackened,
wriggling sheet of drowning creatures."
The tale ended with the footnote: "This is
exactly what might take place and what will
take place if the liners are sent to sea short
of boats."
Stead seemed almost obsessed with the idea,
and it wasn't the only time he wrote about
tragedy at sea.
In the 1892 Christmas edition of The Review
of Reviews, he wrote a tale called "From the
Old World to the New," and told the story
of the White Star Liner Majestic, whose passengers
witness a ship colliding with icebergs, sinking,
and ultimately returning to rescue the survivors.
He described the sinking in vivid detail,
witnessed by one of the passengers on the
nearby liner: "The waters bubbled and foamed.
I could see the heads of a few swimmers in
the eddy.
One after another they sank, and I saw them
no more."
Stead often predicted his own death would
come at the end of a hangman's noose, or by
drowning.
And not only was he right, but in hindsight,
that bit of fiction written from the point
of view of a man drowning amongst hundreds,
and his story about the White Star Liner Majestic
and a daring rescue at sea after a collision
with an iceberg -- that was more prophetic
than he possibly could have known.
It was President William Howard Taft who requested
his presence at a Carnegie Hall peace congress
in 1912, and to get there, he booked passage
on the Titanic.
His first class ticket cost £26 11s; he charmed
other passengers with his stories before he
was ultimately among the lives claimed by
the disaster.
It's unclear how he spent his last hours;
there are various witness testimonies that
claim to have seen him in the hours after
the Titanic's fateful collision.
Some claim to have seen him reading on the
stern of the ship as it rose into the night
sky; others say he spent his last hours sitting
in the First Class Smoking Room, and still
others say he was spotted leading women and
children through the chaos and seeing them
to the lifeboats.
According to at least one testimony, taken
from a survivor named Phillip Mock, Stead
actually had made it to a raft alongside Colonel
John Jacob Astor.
They had been in the water, clinging to the
side, and Mock related, "Their feet became
frozen, and they were compelled to release
their hold.
Both were drowned."
Regardless of how he spent his last moments,
his Spiritualist associates would later claim
he had reached out from the Great Beyond to
tell them of the tragedy, and that was how
they first heard the news.
His body was never recovered, or at least,
was never identified.
If his earlier works had been prophetic, he
seemed not to have expected his end to come
in the way he'd written -- at one point, he
had also written that he expected to be back
home in London by May of 1912.